like many teachers every year on the
first day of school
I lead a sort of icebreaker activity
with my students I teach a Lincoln High
School in Lincoln Nebraska and we are
one of the oldest and most diverse high
schools in our state also to our
knowledge we're the only high school in
the world whose mascot is the Lynx like
a chain and with that being our mascot
we have a statue out front of our
building of four links connected like a
chain and each link means something our
links stand for tradition excellence
unity and diversity so on the first day
of school I teach my new 9th graders
about the meaning behind those links and
I give them each a slip of paper on that
paper I ask them to write something
about themselves it can be something
that they love something that they hope
for anything that describes their
identity and then I go around the room
with a stapler and I staple each of
those slips together to make a chain and
we hang that chain up in our classroom
as a decoration sure but also as a
reminder that we are all connected we
are all links so what happens when one
of those links feels weak and what
happens when that weakness is in the
person holding the stapler the person
who's supposed to make those connections
the teacher as teachers we work every
day to provide support socially
emotionally and academically to our
students who come to us with diverse and
tough circumstances like most teachers I
have students who go home every day and
they sit around a kitchen table
while one or both parents makes a
healthy well-rounded meal for them they
spend supper time summarizing the story
they read in ninth grade English that
day or explaining how Newton's laws of
motion work but also have students who
go to the homeless shelter or to the
group home they go to the car that their
family is sleeping in right now they
come to school with trauma and when I go
home every day that goes home with me
and see that's the hard part about
teaching it's not the grading the lesson
planning the meetings though sure those
things do occupy a great deal of
teachers time and energy the tough part
about teaching is all the things you
can't control for your kids all the
things you can't change for them once
they walk out your door and so I wonder
if it's always been this way I think
back to my undergraduate training at the
University of Georgia where we were
taught in our methods classes that the
concept of good teaching has changed
we're not developing learners who are
going to go out into a workforce where
they'll stand on a line in a factory
rather we're sending our kids out into a
workforce where they need to be able to
communicate collaborate and
problem-solve and that has caused
teacher-student relationships to morph
into something stronger than the giver
of content and the receiver of knowledge
lectures and sitting in silent rows just
doesn't cut it anymore we have to be
able to build relationships with and
among our students to help them feel
connected in a world that depends on it
I think back to my second year teaching
I had a student who I'll call David and
I remember feeling like I've done a
pretty good job of teaching that year
hey I don't know I know first year
teacher I know what I'm doing and it was
on the last day of school
I told David to have a great summer and
I watched him walk down the hall and I
thought to myself I don't even know what
his voice sounds like and that's when I
realized I wasn't doing it right so I
changed almost everything about my
teaching I built in plenty of
opportunities for my students to talk to
me and to talk to each other to share
their writing and to verbalize their
learning and it was through those
conversations I began not only to know
their voice but to know their pain I had
David in classic in that next year and I
learned that his father was undocumented
and had been deported he started acting
out in school because all he wanted was
for his family to be together again in
so many ways I felt his pain and I
needed someone to listen somebody to
provide support for me so that I could
support him in this thing that I could
not even comprehend and we recognized
that need for police officers who've
witnessed a gruesome crime scene and
nurses who have lost a patient but when
it comes to teaching professionals that
urgency is lagging I believe it's
paramount that students and teachers
administrators paraprofessionals and all
other support staff have convenient and
affordable access to mental wellness
supports when we are constantly serving
others often between 25 and a hundred
and 25 students each day our emotional
piggy banks are constantly being drawn
upon after a while it can become so
depleted that we just can't bear it
anymore they call it secondary trauma
and compassion fatigue the concept that
we absorb
the traumas our students share with us
each day and after a while our souls
become weighed down by the heaviness of
it all the Buffett Institute at the
University of Nebraska recently found
that most teachers 86 percent across
early childhood settings experienced
some depressive symptoms during the
prior week they found that approximately
one in ten reported clinically
significant depressive symptoms my
interactions with colleagues and my own
experiences make me feel like this is a
universal struggle across all grade
levels so what are we missing
what are we allowing to break the chain
and how do we repair it in my career
I've experienced the death by suicide of
two students and one amazing teacher who
loved his kids countless students
experiencing homelessness and kids
entering and exiting the justice system
when these events happen protocol is to
say if you need someone to talk to then
and I say that's not enough I am so
lucky I work in an amazing school with
great leadership I serve a large
district with so many healthy
partnerships with community agencies
they have provided steadily increasing
numbers of school counselors and
therapists and support staff to help our
students they even provide staff members
with access to free counseling as part
of our employment plan but many small
districts and even some large ones
simply cannot foot the bill without aid
not only does every school need social
and emotional support staff trained
professionals who can navigate the needs
of the building not just the students
not just the teachers but both we also
need these trained professionals to
intentionally seek out those closest to
the trauma and check in with them many
schools are doing what they can to fill
in the gaps
starting with acknowledging that the
work that we do is downright hard
another school in Lincoln's NGO middle
school has what they call wellness
Wednesdays they invite in community yoga
teachers they sponsor walks around the
neighborhood during lunch and organize
social events that are all meant to
bring people together
Zachary Elementary School in Zachary
Louisiana has something they call a
midweek Meetup
where they invite teachers to share
lunch and to talk about the things that
are going well and the things that are
weighing heavy on their hearts these
schools are making space for
conversations that matter
finally my friend and colleague gin high
street takes five minutes out of each
day to write an encouraging note to a
colleague letting them know that she
sees their hard work and the heart that
they share with others she knows that
those five minutes can have an
invaluable and powerful ripple effect
across our school the chain that hangs
in my classroom is more than just a
decoration those links hang over our
heads for the entire four years that our
students walk our halls and every year I
have seniors come back to my classroom
room 340 and they can still point out
where they're linked hangs they remember
what they wrote on it they feel
connected and supported and they have
hope
now what we all need somebody to reach
out and make sure that we're okay to
check in with us and remind us that we
are a link every now and then we all
just need a little help
holding the stapler thank you